to me i don't think there's anything
like stopping us from doing any role
today you don't think so no nothing i
think if i i think if i wanted to be ceo
i could be a ceo i think you could but
yeah it'd be a lot more difficult in
comparison for when a man tries to
become a ceo but you realize there's
like specific grants for women that
aren't given to men i don't think that
that one event is but that's like makeup
for like sisters i don't yeah i don't
think that makes up for like the
majority of technology and i t world
being like male dominated so how do you
know the difference between women just
choosing stuff that they're interested
in
like for example i don't know a lot of
girls that want to be plumbers and i
used to work for a plumbing tech company
so we like sold stuff to plumbers and we
would go to schools and it would be like
one two plum like female plumbers in the
room and plumbers make a lot of money
right it's just not like a glorified job
but how do you know the difference
between women not um wanting to do those
jobs
and
and like discrimination because at the
other end of the spectrum like my dad
he's the ceo of a company and my dad
worked 80 hours a week my whole life to
get to that position right like since i
was i barely saw him my whole life i
don't know many girls that would want to
do that
like
so so
yeah
but like how do you know that because
you're talking about like systemic like
like discrimination that's against us
but how do you know the difference
between women like choosing what they
want to do and just
and discrimination